The establishment left has just dropped entirely.
So the democratic party, whatever that is,
abandoned the working class a generation ago.
Okay.
Let's get straight into the questions.
Is that all right?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So Peter, you can mute your mic if you don't
mind.
Got it.
Okay.
What I wanted to know is the first,
I wanted to define the left and essentially
the way that I'm going to do that
is by asking you, what are the traits in the
left, the left,
political left in the past century that have
changed and what's remained the
same as far as you can tell?
Well, of course,
the left has moved consistently to new
issues that weren't even noticed before.
So if you go back a century, well,
there were elements of the left that you could
call, say, feminist.
It's nothing like the dominant,
the dominant element in left
politics that exists today.
You go back 20 years ago,
there was very little concern about the environment.
Now the left recognizes that it's an existential
problem.
On the other hand,
and so there are many cases in which there's
been progress in understanding
and dedicated work.
There are other cases in which there's regression.
So go back not very far,
a couple of decades,
labor organizing was a major issue for the
left.
It was recognized and understood that the
driving force in any
social and political economic change is going
to be an organized working class.
That's been,
well, it depends what you call the left,
but the establishment left has just dropped
it entirely.
So the democratic party,
whatever that is,
abandoned the working class a generation ago,
handed it over to their class enemy.
Activists on the left have become engaged
justifiably with issues that are sometimes
called identity
politics.
Those are real issues, have to be dealt with.
But class issues have been subordinated,
marginalized, and they're very real.
That's a deficiency that has to be overcome.
All of these things interact when people talk
about intersectionality,
yes, they're right,
but it's been more of a slogan than an actual
achievement.
So I think if you look across the board, there's
progress and regression.
What is your opinion on identity politics?
The issues are significant.
They have to, they cannot,
each type of identity politics cannot dominate
a commitment of an organized left that hopes
to achieve things.
They have to interact,
be mutually supportive and they have to crucially
bring in the class issues that
have been subordinated.
Actually the most active extreme form of identity
politics is white nationalism.
Something I'm trying to determine with my
research is when does the left go too
far and when does the right go too far, politically
speaking?
And I wanted to know what your opinion is
on that.
Just to pick the issues.
I mean, the right at this point is simply
suicidal.
It's not a question of going too far.
The right is committed to destruction of organized
human society.
Is that an extreme statement?
Maybe, but it's correct.
Just take a look at the Republican party.
What is the Republican party committed to?
It's committed to destroying human life and
not in the long term.
The Paris agreements a couple of years ago,
they weren't fabulous, but they were something
at least.
Their original effort intent was to destroy
the human race.
It was to create a treaty in which there would
be verifiable commitments to some
measures to avert the huge threat of global
warming.
Couldn't get a treaty.
It had to be a voluntary agreement.
Why?
Republican senators wouldn't accept it.
I take the Republican primary in 2016.
Every single candidate, without exception,
either denied that global warming is taking
place
or else said, maybe it is, but we don't care.
John Kasich, who was the governor of Ohio,
who's considered the real moderate of the
group,
said, yeah, we recognize that global warming
is taking place and it's serious,
but we in Ohio are going to use our coal and
we're not going to apologize for it.
That's the moderate Republican.
Then you go over to the White House.
You have total maniacs.
People who say we don't care.
I said, we'll destroy the world, but we'll
have profit tomorrow and are leading the way
towards destruction, consciously aware of
what they're doing.
No secret about it.
Easy to demonstrate.
How far to the right is this?
I mean, there's no words for it.
One question.
What about the left?
When does the left go too far?
It's not a matter of going too far.
It's a matter of making tactical decisions
that are incorrect.
You have to, if you, you may, there's, it
may be that some of the goals go to, are debatable.
Talk about that.
But insofar as they're the kinds of goals
that, say, we think we can support,
you have to ask whether the tactics that are
used are well designed to meet those goals
or else undermine the goals.
So let's take concrete cases.
As you know, I was very active in the anti-war
movement, resistance movement during the 1960s.
I had contact with Vietnamese.
The Vietnamese were appalled by some of the
tactics that were being used.
I remember meetings where the Vietnamese would
plead with American activists not to do things
like what the weathermen are doing.
The weathermen, a lot of young people, many
of them I knew, they were perfectly sincere.
They thought that the way to end the war is
to smash up the windows on Main Street.
It's not the way to end the war.
That was the way to enrage construction workers
and others, so they'd be more pro-war than
they were before.
The Vietnamese didn't care whether Americans
felt good.
They cared whether they could survive.
So what they advocated were measures so mild
that a lot of the war movement would just
laugh at them.
But that's the kind of choice that has to
be made all the time.
I can give you many examples today.
So going too far, I think the way we should
rephrase that is picking tactics that are
going to undermine
the perhaps legitimate and just goals that
you say you're advocating.
On the discussion of the left and the right,
in terms of their differences and their similarities,
oftentimes the left are characterized as being
pro-government and the right is characterized
as being pro-corporation.
And you have written about the revolving door
between the two, between regulators and the
regulated, in your book like Manufacturing
Consent.
Now, does this blur the line of what it means
to be a left-winger and a right-winger?
Do the left and the right still exist?
Did they ever exist?
I mean, let's take being pro- or anti-government.
That's not a general position of the left.
That's a tactical choice in particular circumstances.
So when you have a state like the United States
that's largely dominated by private tyrannies
with very little public voice,
in that particular circumstance, the option
available to you to overcome this is governmental
action,
which at least to some extent is responsive
to public opinion.
In other circumstances, when you're trying
to construct a really libertarian left participatory
society,
you might want to dissolve governmental structures
as a legitimate authority.
There's no right or wrong answer to that.
So, for example, let's take, say, media.
The United States is unusual.
It's different from other developed societies
in many respects.
One respect is it doesn't have public, barely
has public media.
Media are privatized, overwhelming.
It's kind of a little tiny fringe on the left,
nothing like, off the fringe.
So it's like nothing like the BBC or anything
like that.
We can look at why this happened.
Certainly not implicit in U.S. history, like
the founders of the country, the framers,
believe they interpreted the First Amendment
very differently than the way we do.
They thought it meant that the government
ought to take an active role in sponsoring
a free and independent press.
That's why we have the post office, for example.
In its early years, the post office was almost
totally devoted to providing a cheap,
free, basically subsidies to a wide variety
of journals and newspapers
to encourage a varied, free, independent press.
Over the years, the power of private power
in the United States,
which is quite unusual, managed to privatize
radio, television and more recently, the Internet.
But that's and yes, in those circumstances,
it would make sense to call for a public voice.
Under other circumstances, you might want
to have local, local
based, you know, worker based, community based
media.
And there's many other such questions.
You're a self-described anarchist, and I'd
like to know what is the difference between
your beliefs and contemporary libertarianism?
Well, first of all, what's called libertarian
in the United States is some ultra right advocacy
of private tyrannies.
Nothing, nothing like anything that was libertarian
traditionally.
But if you're talking about left libertarian,
it's.
You know, covers quite a range, but just as
the term anarchism does.
But there is a kind of a core at the center
of it, I think.
The core running through the whole tradition,
many variations,
is the recognition that there are certain
structures
in social, political life, economic life that
are that have to justify their own legitimacy.
They are coercive, authoritarian.
There is hierarchy, domination.
Somebody gives you or somebody takes them.
All of those structures have to be are none
of those structures are self-justifying.
They have a burden of justification.
If they can't meet it, which is almost always
the case, they should be dismantled.
I think that's the core principle.
And my own view is that once you get to the
basics, almost every normal person is an anarchist
in this sense.
But that's then you have to ask how it applies.
So do you have a job somewhere?
Well, if you have a job in a business corporation,
let's say you're living in a tyranny.
So extreme that no totalitarian dictator ever
dreamed of it.
So, for example, Stalin didn't tell people
that you have 10 minutes to go to the bathroom
every couple hours.
You have to wear these clothes, not some other
clothes.
You're not allowed to stop to talk to a friend
for a minute.
You're monitored, say, at an Amazon warehouse.
So that if you don't pick up enough things
fast enough, like maybe you stop to breathe
or something,
you get a demerit.
There was no totalitarian dictatorship like
that.
That's most of people's lives.
Well, is that a legitimate structure?
Is the labor contract legitimate?
Actually, traditional classical liberals didn't
think so.
Abraham Lincoln didn't think so.
The Republican Party didn't think so.
The Republican Party's slogan in the mid-19th
century, early Industrial Revolution, was
that
wage labor is indistinguishable from slavery,
except that it's supposed to be temporary
until you become a free person again.
Well, OK, those ideas have been driven out
of people's heads, but I don't think they're
very far below the surface.
They can emerge.
And that would be authentic left libertarianism,
just one aspect.
Crucial aspect.
So it seems like you overlap with regards
to free exchange of speech and ideas.
And I remember a while ago you helped, you
defended a Holocaust denier.
And I wanted to know if you still stand by
that.
Defending a Holocaust denier?
I mean, defending his freedom of speech.
Sure.
I mean, this is just standard classical liberalism.
There's two choices.
Either some form of power and authority, typically
the state or other, determines what's true
and punishes any deviation from what it claims
is true.
Or else you allow views to be expressed that
you don't like.
In fact, if you really believe in freedom
of speech, the only issues are, do I allow
speech that I don't like?
Hitler and Stalin had nothing against speech
that they liked.
Nowadays, there's this trans rights versus
free speech debate.
And I want to know what you think about that.
Where do you lie on that?
Let's talk about Holocaust denial for another
minute.
The Holocaust denial is the norm in Western
society.
So, just to take an example, a couple of years
ago, an article appeared in the New York Review,
the major journal of left liberalism, in which
the author, good, decent left liberal, was
reviewing a book by a major American historian.
He said in his review, he was interested to
learn that when the early explorers came to
the Western Hemisphere, there were only about
a million people from the tropical forests
to the frozen north.
He was off by about 60 or 70 million who were
wiped out.
Is that Holocaust denial?
Did anybody say he should be imprisoned?
Did anybody even notice?
I mean, these things happen all the time.
It's a particular form that we don't like,
that somebody doesn't like, that's considered,
that has to be suppressed.
And that's worth keeping in mind when you
talk about Holocaust denial.
So, it seems like you have some similarities
with Jordan Peterson on this issue.
And I know that you haven't talked much about
Jordan Peterson.
And I wanted to know if you had any disagreements
with what he says.
Frankly, I pay very little attention.
But if you want to know about Jordan Peterson,
I think the best thing I can refer you to
is an article by Nathan Robinson, a very sharp,
acute critic in his journal Current Affairs.
It's called something like The Intellectual
We Deserve or something like that.
I think that's basically my answer.
Other than that, I don't pay any attention.
I mean, there's some issues on which I probably
agree with Hitler.
No, it doesn't mean much.
On that subject, I think it's Aristotle, right,
who says that people get the governments they
deserve.
Is this kind of the line?
Aristotle said that people get the governments
they deserve.
Is this kind of what you're implying, but
for intellectuals?
No, I don't think people get the government
they deserve.
They get the government that power systems
impose.
That's quite different.
On the systems of power, you had mentioned
in Manufacturing Consent the idea of the principle
of bureaucratic affinity, the idea that large
scale bureaucracies will ally with other large
scale bureaucracies to sort of maintain a
status quo and to aid each other.
And that when a company like when a media
company, for example, tries true journalism,
these large bureaucracies be either the government
or corporations will give the media company
flack and sort of cease to work with them.
My question for you is, does the principle
of bureaucratic affinity apply to educational
institutions like large universities?
To a varying extent.
Depends on the university, depends on the
time and the era.
You know, there's in our current situation,
current circumstances with all their flaws,
the universities are one of the last bastions
of relative freedom of expression and research.
Even of worker self-government to a certain
extent.
Faculty at a university has a degree of control
over their working lives, which is very rare
in the existing socio-political system.
So I don't think you can answer a simple yes
or no.
By comparative standards, they're relatively
free.
They have flaws.
So, for example, if you take a look at the
American university system, well, about just
a few years ago, you couldn't find a Marxist
professor anywhere.
Any other country in the world, they'd be
all over the place.
Not here.
May I ask what do you attribute that to?
In your in past comments, you had mentioned
how academics maintain a sort of status quo
as opposed to being the sort of radicals that
they display themselves as.
Do you find that still true?
Or do you find that academics are changing?
Well, and there's a kind of an ebb and flow.
I think it's less true than it was 50 or 60
years ago.
But it's more true than it ought to be.
And it's not just academics.
It's intellectuals generally.
Look over the whole history of intellectuals
for a couple of thousand years, in fact.
And you find that overwhelmingly, they tend
to stay in the middle.
A couple of thousand years, in fact.
And you find that overwhelmingly, they tend
to support power systems.
There are a few who don't.
They're usually treated pretty harshly.
In fact, just take the term intellectual in
its modern sense, was first used at the time
of the Dreyfus trial in France, late 19th
century.
Most of the intellectuals, the prestigious
intellectuals, the ones of the French Academy
and so on, bitterly condemned the Dreyfus
arts.
How dare these writers and artists question
the majesty of our army, state and so on.
And there were a few like Emil Zola, a couple
of others who stood up against it.
They were persecuted.
And we may honor them today, but not at the
time.
And Emil Zola had to flee France.
That's the record in one form or another,
all through history.
So, in fact, shortly after this, the First
World War came along.
It was very dramatic to see what happened
to the intellectual classes during this, including
the left, during the First World War.
In every single country, Germany, France,
England, the United States, the intellectuals
lined up almost 100 percent in passionate
support of their own country.
The ones who didn't, many of them ended up
in jail.
Bertrand Russell, Rosa Luxemburg, Gene Debs.
That's the pattern.
We're back, we're back.
Peter, do you want to repeat the question?
Super quick.
This is my wife.
Hi, thank you.
Thank you.
Hello, Professor Noam Chomsky's wife.
Okay.
The question in summary was, in Manufacturing
Consent, you teach us that big media is allied
with the government, corporate elites.
As a result, the framework of big media's
discussion fits comfortably in a propaganda
model, an acceptable framework on how to analyze
problems and talk about issues.
Well, if academia itself is allied with government
and corporate elites, then wouldn't they also
fit a propaganda model?
And if not, what makes them so unique?
Well, for one thing, there's several things
that are, to some extent, it's true.
But notice that the relation of media to,
say, corporate elites is very different from
the relation of universities to corporate
elites.
In the case of media, it's just, that's what
they are.
The media are major corporations, parts of
bigger corporations.
Flow in and out of government, you know, very
heavily subject to government edicts and so
on.
Universities have the same influences, but
much less so.
The relation of a university to corporations
is, can I get a grant?
You know, will I get a, will there be a donor
who will be willing to build a building?
That's very different from being part of the
corporate system, which already allows a little
flexibility.
Also, there is, we should not underestimate
the fact that there is a sense of professionalism
and intellectual responsibility.
That's true.
There are serious journalists, many of them
who understand the system very well.
They didn't have to hear it from us and who
try to find ways to combat it.
And it happens now in the media, they tend
to be marginalized and eliminated.
You know, they don't have to be, you know,
they don't have to be in the media.
You know, sent to the police desk, you're
not really ready for big time work, you know,
that sort of thing.
And that kind of thing happens in the universities
too, but probably to a slightly lesser extent.
And it depends also on the field.
So many fields in the university are almost
totally free from outside pressures.
The physics department, for instance.
Some people have suggested that they should,
that we should remove universities.
And this is reminiscent, Jordan Peterson,
for example, said, suggests to students, don't
go to universities anymore because of the
bias, because of the unitary point of views.
And this is reminiscent of anarchist Yvonne
Illman, who said, you know, we should not
go to universities.
Listen to what Jordan Peterson is saying.
He's saying universities are dominated by
the left.
Now for him, the left, is anybody to the left
of Attila the Hun.
In fact, universities are dominated by the
right.
He's so far on the right that that looks like
the left to him.
And so he's saying, you know, we should eliminate
universities.
But the right is people who will say that
university is dominated by the left.
But does it make sense to tell students not
to go to universities?
It's crazy.
It's one of the places where you can, there's
lots of things wrong,
but there are resources and opportunities
that simply don't exist anywhere else.
You can't, there are opportunities to become
a free, independent, creative individual,
working with others that you just don't have
elsewhere.
Sorry, I misspoke.
I didn't mean that to suggest that he suggested
to eliminate the universities.
I'm more trying to convey the decentralizing
of universities.
So for example, an online school.
There's a lot you miss in an online school.
Your peers.
One of the big parts of education is the students
you're with.
That those kinds of interactions are gone
online.
And they're very important for educating oneself.
Anybody who's been in a, through a school
or university situation knows how you can
learn more from interaction with your peers
than from sitting in on a lecture.
Even interaction with the faculty.
So it's one thing to sit in a lecture class
or watch a television screen.
And it's another thing to be in an actual
class where you're interacting with other
students and with the faculty.
So yes, there are good things.
I mean, I think it's good to try to extend
the resources of the university elsewhere.
But there's nothing to replace the direct
face to face interaction.
Not just when you're in class, but when you're
doing something else.
When you're sitting in a McDonald's and having
a hamburger with your friends and talking.
What are your thoughts on the Christian anarchist,
Ivan Illich, and his rise in popularity amongst
social activists?
An anarchist who believed in de-schooling
society.
His popular work.
I sort of understand some of the motivation
for it.
But de-schooling society is taking away from
people some of their major opportunities for
individual growth and social interaction.
And even general activism.
I mean, it's not just pure accident that over
the years, student activism has been typically
at the forefront of many of the most important
social movements.
Partly it's just because young people are
a period of their life when they're relatively
free.
But it's also the fact that they're together.
They can talk with one another.
They can interact.
Something that's pretty much missing and atomized
in capitalist society.
Then I'm running into a little bit of a confusion
here.
On the one hand, the history of intellectuals
and academia sort of lines up with the status
quo.
In the sense that we were talking about Nazism
and things before.
But on the other hand, they're on the forefront
of social change.
How are these views compatible?
Their participants are in the forefront of
social change.
The mainstream may be status quo and conservative,
which it is.
Take a look at student activism.
It's usually opposed by the administration
and most of the faculty.
But nevertheless, it takes place.
Because this is a relatively free institution.
Which means that there are opportunities to
break out of the doctrinaire system of attempted
regimentation.
We're not living in totalitarian dictatorships
where if you say the wrong thing, you get
sent to the concentration camp.
We're living in societies with a relative
degree of freedom.
Often infringed by authoritarian structures.
But they don't have the kind of force they
do if the SS troops are standing behind you.
We shouldn't compare ourselves with that.
In that case, what is an anarcho-syndicalist
take on education?
On what it should look like and what needs
to change?
From how it is now to how it should be.
Actually, the anarchist movement, not just
the anarcho-syndicalists, were in the forefront
of developing.
Progressive education systems.
So for example, in Spain, where the 1936 revolution
was the most successful.
So for example, of the anarchist revolution.
That was preceded by decades of educational
efforts in villages and towns everywhere.
Trying to create a free, liberatory environment.
In which students could find their own ways.
Their creativity would be sponsored.
They would work jointly with one another.
Very similar to progressive education tendencies
of John Dewey and others.
Which I happened to benefit from as a child.
In fact, I'm familiar with and taught that
way as well.
So yes, anarchist education has been very
progressive.
There's also people like Paulo Freire who
argued that it should be an interactive process.
Where the teacher is learning from the students.
Not just students.
Having an opportunity for freedom.
That's what I think is the kind of direction
that education should take.
The course that it should follow and does
in the better places.
Do you feel that if education is too centralized,
these alternative platforms will be sidelined?
Neglected in the public sphere?
Or for example, in universities that student
participation would get minimized?
I don't think there's a simple answer.
You could have a public education system.
Which fosters individual creativity, freedom,
student initiative and so on.
You could have a scattered system of charter
schools.
Which are business run and which impose discipline.
It depends on the educational program.
Not whether it's central or not.
It depends.
I have a question that either you would think
is completely polar opposite or that they
completely overlap.
What were you thinking during your interview,
your conversation with Foucault?
And what were you thinking during your conversation
with Ali G?
With Ali G?
I didn't hear the first one.
With Foucault and with Ali G.
Well, it's quite different.
In the case of Ali G, I was not particularly
interested in the interview.
But I think it was the BBC or whoever was
behind it.
They gave me a big song and dance about it.
It was going to be a very serious interview.
So I finally agreed.
As soon as he walked in, I realized this is
a joke.
I tried to be polite.
I had a hard time with it.
I didn't take it seriously enough.
You mean to say you realized that it was a
joke?
Or you felt like the whole interview was a
joke and you thought he was for real?
The whole thing was obviously some kind of
an efforted comedy, which I didn't want to
be part of.
And I was perfectly, I mean, I was on the
tip of my tongue saying, look, this is enough.
Let's terminate it.
But being polite, I went along with it for
a while.
Foucault is quite different.
Actually, we had spent, Foucault and I had
spent a large part of the day together.
The interview was in the evening.
I was just walking around the Dutch countryside.
Partly because we wanted to have a chance
to talk, but partly to see if we could get
by with him talking French and me talking
English.
Would we be able to understand each other?
Or should we have a translator?
We finally figured we could carry it off.
I don't know much French.
He doesn't know much English, but it worked.
And the debate was about issues that are fairly
serious issues.
So nothing before archaeology.
We disagreed about a lot of things.
I was kind of appalled by some of his views.
But it was within the domain of rational discourse.
Okay.
I know you're a busy person.
I only have two more questions, and they're
super quick.
One is, what are your thoughts on postmodernism?
What do you agree with and what do you disagree
with?
Well, for about a couple of decades, I've
had a very simple question that I've been
posing to my postmodern friends.
Can you find something in postmodernism which
is not either a triviality cloaked in polysyllables
or is false?
And nobody's answered it yet.
So that's about all I can say.
Okay.
And then my last question was, you're extremely
prolific.
You've written, I think, over 100 books, at
least on politics, and then many more on other
subjects.
How do you structure your day?
What's your productivity look like?
Your routine?
Well, right now, since my wife Valeria and
I moved to Arizona, not living in Cambridge
anymore, my routine is to get up early in
the morning, take our dogs out, play with
them for a while.
Then read the newspaper and start looking
at the huge quantity of email that piled up.
If I can get rid of that, get to work on serious
things.
Ah, but did you clean your room?
I'm just kidding.
I said, ah, but did you clean your room?
Clean my room?
Jordan Peterson reference.
There's very little oxygen in the room.
It's mostly books and papers.
It's not much clean.
Thank you so much, Professor, and thank you.
What's your wife's name?
Valeria?
Valeria.
Hi.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'll send you a link to this interview as
well.
I'll give you a copy of the interview.
Sure.
Okay.
Thank you.